[Music]
the part of brain we work on it's called
the basal ganglia and these visions of
the brain lie deep underneath the cortex
which is the part most people know about
and see in all the pictures of the brain
and that's a beautiful rind of nervous
tissue on the outside of the brain and
it's probably our strongest computer
it's a fabulous machine but underneath
that our deep line brain nuclei and the
basal ganglia are the largest of these
and they're tremendously important in a
number of disorders Parkinson's disease
Huntington's OCD obsessive-compulsive
disorder Tourette so depression how can
all these disorders be related to one
set of nuclei in the brain and if this
cerebral cortex is so special in our
great computer what is it that these
other brain regions do so when we set
out to study them not much was known
about these the structures partly
because they're deep it's hard to hard
to study them very difficult to study
them so we were in the very lucky
position of discovering like an
archaeologist a town that had been
buried and not that much was known about
it and so we could just begin to look at
the road maps but what were the inputs
and the outputs and there are so many
neurotransmitters that are the chemical
messengers in the brain and this region
is very very rich in these and so again
we were lucky because we could begin to
map out these chemical messengers in
relation to the traffic flow coming in
and out and so that's where we started
and then
that turned out well gee when we learned
about this architecture it looked a lot
like learning architectures that had
been studied by the computational people
who are interested in the logic of the
brain and so we were very excited by
that because it meant that maybe this
region of the brain that we were
specializing on had a lot to do with
taking inputs from that great cortical
computer and reconfiguring them mixing
them up making new combinations and then
helping the outflow of the system
produce actions and the more we looked
the more it became clear from the whole
field it's not just our work that the
outflow goes not only to motor actions
as is so famous in the case of the
terrible disorders such as Parkinson's
disease or Huntington's disease but the
outflow also goes to organize our
cognitive actions if you will the way we
think
whether we're up we're down whether
we're happy or not so it's a very very
rich system and we were lucky to be
early in on trying to work on it so I
guess what this has led to is that we
now are looking very very hard at what
how this system might learn how do we
learn the kinds of things that are are
mediated by the system for example
there's a lot of evidence that the basal
ganglia have to do with learning habits
learning just simple behavioral routines
just the kinds of things that all of us
do and so it turns out if you really
think about it that most of what we do
every day we do without really thinking
about that's it's almost the definition
of a habit and what that means is that
we're that frees up our big cognitive
machine to do all sorts of other things
to take in new inputs think great
thoughts I'm at MIT they're brilliant
people here maybe think of a new
equation
something about the origin of the
universe so having this deep brain
system helping us get regularities in
our lives is tremendously important
so contributing even a little bit to
this whole enterprise of learning about
these structures and how they influence
this cerebral cortex our big computer
has been what we've done and we're very
very privileged to be able to work on it
it's it's a very wonderful thing that
people are becoming aware of Parkinson's
and how many people can become afflicted
with it and and the whole family of
disorders related to Parkinson's disease
and and I thinking about what we've
learned it's there's an explosion of new
information that's directly relevant to
trying to develop therapies and even
prevent Parkinson's disease many forms
of Parkinson's disease are not
hereditary but some are the fact that
some are means that people are able now
to go and find the genes that are
responsible for those hereditary forms
by getting your hands on genes means
getting your hands on the molecules that
control the way the neurons function so
that surely is terribly important and
then coming to these neural circuits and
chemical coating of them the primary
cause of Parkinson's disease is the loss
of the neurotransmitter dopamine it's an
amazing neurotransmitter really a
remarkable system and as this dopamine
and it's nervous tracks died back then
Parkinson's and Susan so therapies now
are directed toward replacing the
dopamine or most recently in using for
example either a lesion in the brain or
stimulation deep in the brain to help
undo the damage that the loss of
dopamine
done and I I guess crude analogy would
would be that in Parkinson's disease the
wrong messages are coming out of the
basal ganglia and they're really wrong
it's sort of like static coming out of a
radio or a hi-fi and so getting rid of a
static even though it may not produce a
perfectly normal brain nevertheless is a
tremendous help to many people with this
disorder and with related disorders
disorders related to Parkinson's disease
so things are very hopeful so why is it
so difficult to get at the root disorder
in Tourette's syndrome or
obsessive-compulsive disorder and those
I might say are well known examples of
examples of a whole family of disorders
and so let me come back like one more
time to this idea of circuits so imagine
that we have this beautiful cortex which
is computing things about the world and
that then the basal ganglia are
interacting with this system over and
over again in a in a giant neural loop
so to say it's now thought that that
loop at least one very particular part
of that loop is disordered in OCD
obsessive-compulsive disorder and
probably in Tourette syndrome - so what
does that mean
so for example in obsessive-compulsive
disorder people may have a huge
uncontrollable feeling that they have to
do something somebody leaves the house
says gee did I remember to take the
things I had to take so they go back in
the house they check it it's okay and
they leave and then they are really uh
cest with did I really have what I
needed to take when they go back and so
and so on so these obsessional ideas
leave people to do things repetitively
over and over again so one idea is that
the reason it's difficult to understand
every little piece of the neural
mechanism underlying this these
disorders is that they aren't disorders
of one tiny little piece of brain but of
a whole neural network which is turning
away and somehow got stuck so things are
going over and over again and so what
we're trying to do is study the neural
basis of repetitive behaviors and my
colleagues and I have been trying to
understand what genes are turned on in
the brain when in model systems
repetitive behaviors are are generated
just over and over again and also what
neural systems what's exactly the loop
and what are the neurotransmitters
exactly in that disordered loop so if we
can find that out then we're a long long
way forward toward therapy yes so the
question is what is the basis of
addiction and how do we form habits and
how our habits related to addiction or
addictive behaviors if they are at all
and what are we doing in the lab and so
let me just say that one of the things
that we are studying we're very
interested in how we learn habits how we
learn them and then how habits can be
broken how do you make a habit how do
you break and have it how come some
habits are good and some habits are bad
and and why is it that sometimes
something that seems relatively
innocuous like having one cigarette
could lead to a real addiction to
cigarettes or to any other substance
that tends to make us do it again and
again and want it more and more and
I must say that it's been thrilling to
begin to look at the neural basis of
habit formation because what we're
seeing and others too is that as an
animal acquires a simple habit just a
simple simple little habit the neurons
in the basal ganglia and also in the
cortex these nerve cells really
dramatically changed the way they fire
they they become interested in quotes in
different aspects of the outside world
and and so they they develop a whole new
kind of world map where one thing or one
trigger becomes very important and then
the other thing that seems to happen is
it as we do develop these habits we
release these animals do then in the
brain the various elements of the whole
action let's say we have a habit of you
know putting your hand in your pocket
and rattling your keys right or fiddling
with your hair or something like that
actually if you look at it any one of
these little mannerisms or habits that
we have any one is made up of many
different components little sub parts so
one of the things we think is that maybe
as habits are formed these get chunk
together so they naturally link to each
other and then bang if you see the
trigger or you have the internal trigger
coming out of your brain or your mind
then the whole thing comes out and you
know that's what makes it so hard one of
the things that makes it so hard to
break a habit you know again if you
think of the person who smokes a
cigarette for example it turns out that
context is so important like you like to
have a cup of coffee or a cigarette or
something in a given place in a given
context or you just see something where
you usually get your cup of coffee and
then you want it really badly so the
triggers for behaviors can become out of
proportion
important to our behavior and that may
be part of what gets these loops going
and some of the very same loops that are
disordered in OCD or Tourette may in
fact be the ones that are driving us
when we have addictive habits but I must
say that there's a very wonderful side
of habits and that's that you have a
habit and you don't have to think say
you get in a car you want to drive you
see a red light you automatically put
your foot on the brake and never even
the curse you don't think it all out
what that means is you can be thinking
of other things and so it is with the
rest of life so really I think it's
profoundly important to understand what
neurotransmitters what genes what neural
pathways what loops in the brain are
going when we have normal habit
formation or addictive habit formation
and then what little tricks can we use
to to break the bad ones
that's very central to what we work on
in the lab you know I'm not even sure
that we understand the code that's used
in the brain I don't think there are
many people who would dare to know
whether we are even beginning to know
just the code the language of the brain
we're learning many different potential
codes of the brain and so how far are we
off it's it's anybody's guess but I'll
tell you I think the progress just even
in the last very few years has been
Milus how much we're learning and I you
know I think that's reflected in the
fact that so many people who actually
don't work on the brain for their
livings so many people are getting
interested in the brain because it it's
becoming more accessible to us so you
know our will we know in five years 10
years 15 years 20 years what's the
nature of consciousness or how does the
mind relate to the brain or how is it
that you and I have emotions
that sort of thing III don't think we're
gonna know the answers to that kind of
question very soon but I do think we're
going to be able to help many many many
people people with neurodegenerative
disorders people with various disorders
that affect their brains and one thing
that I'm particularly interested in
adding to the group of things that we
work toward in neuroscience is that we
try to help normal people too because I
think we have extraordinary potential
that has hardly been tapped or maybe
isn't tapped in most of us brain
potential potential to do things to
think things to be happy or sad or to
have fuller lives and I think learning
more about the brain I think that's
going to help us learn how to tap that
potential well I want to say that it's
tremendously meaningful to me to work
with the students and postdocs and
co-workers and staff members it's very
very exciting to see a young person
learn and grow and come of age so I mean
that's part of being a a professor and I
thrill to that but the subject matter to
me is so intrinsically interesting and
so potentially important just for our
daily lives that I must say I I I get a
high so I just feel frankly I feel very
very lucky very privileged and
absolutely determined to do the very
best we can to help people but what we
learn so I just want to say that I'm a
product of MIT I was trained at MIT both
as a grad student and then later as a
faculty member because faculty members
at MIT are always in training and it's
been a
a fantastic experience MIT is a place of
with so many talented people and people
talented in so many different ways and
people can play pranks and and discover
great things so it's it's an enormous
place of energy and I was lucky enough
to to be working in neuroscience and I
think everyone at MIT now knows of the
grades new enthusiasm for neuroscience
at MIT with the development of the
McGovern Institute and the pick our
center and the department of brain and
cognitive science and the real
commitment that MIT feels toward
neuroscience and I can say as a
neuroscientist that that one just feels
the energy of having MIT move forward in
this realm and I believe that this is is
just great for MIT because the brain is
a communication system and MIT is
premiered in the study of all kinds of
communication including fabulous kinds
of virtual reality telecommunication
robotics and so on so this is this is an
extraordinary time at MIT both in my
field in and others and so I just want
to say to the graduating class of 2002
go for it I think the best thing to say
is that I've there will be more and that
I very much hope that in it be some way
I can be a role model that's a tough
thing but I do want to say that I have
I've had the pleasure to have many women
in the lab undergraduates some
undergraduates or graduating today hello
and graduate students postdoctoral
fellows visiting scientists and they're
wonderful they're brilliant
they're they're beautiful they're
they're talented and I think this will
all disappear in the course of time and
then just from my own experience at MIT
the the amount of talent in the group of
women students is just explosive